so
find me
[Music]
hey guys whistleblower here recently
Stephen Crowder took a long Hiatus from
his show because of some bad
complications from surgery apparently
his lung collapsed or something but
don't feel too bad for him yet because
I'm here to tell you that everything
went according to plan buckle up because
this one gets crazy Stephen Crowder is
actually
Amy Schumer
[Music]
I got into this Rabbit Hole after
noticing Amy Schumer was taping her new
TV series around the same time Crowder
was going into surgery
this proves that chowder is surgically
augmenting himself every time he goes on
vacation to live his second life is Amy
Schumer think about it the rivalries
with each other to make themselves more
famous playing both sides so they always
win
and I already know what you're thinking
what about the time they were both on
Fox News I'm already a few steps ahead
of you it's a classic Hollywood spliff
frame trick
so now the only question that remains is
which came first the chowder
or the Schumer
or are they something different
altogether that's all for now I'll see
you guys in the next one whistleblower
out
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I guess of Monday and it's the sound of
you ever forget to breathe what we were
rushing and we were hustling to get
ready for the show and John Oliver you
know who will uh he'll be a wonderful
trophy after Today's Show and then you
just realize you forget to breathe
sometimes just breathe it's always
playing in my head that's true Faith
Hill was right so it was a Chris gravel
Dashboard Confessional amen remember she
asked you remember to breathe so uh look
my first question to you is will you
start using parlor once Kanye uh buys it
that's what's happening today but uh we
had a whole segment ready to go on uh
former Vice President Joe Biden being
creepy with children but more
importantly some things that people Miss
but we'll we'll move that to tomorrow
because John Oliver is trending right
now
and look I say this without a hint of
hyperbole uh they're coming for your
kids there's a 26 minute segment making
the case as to why it's a good thing for
children to transition for children to
get on puberty blockers and it's an
attempt to Gaslight you we'll get it we
have so much again it gets a little bit
wonky but all references are available
at live with credit.com we want to leave
no doubt as it relates to the empirical
Gerald how are you I am doing well my
Irish got beat this weekend that's right
you went to Notre Dame for it
unfortunately yeah you spent all that
time I mean yet again you were
embarrassed I made memories with my
parents mostly of me being angry but I
made them yes why don't you cry about it
I was sure we did he called me he did I
replenished after the stomach flu I just
sat and I had a mission of just eating
ah yes well that sounds more fun no
there have been negative ramifications
to that as well I overshot it I went to
Lou Malnati's Pizza in in Chicago
fantastic oh really so good yeah I bet
you he's just he didn't he went to he's
on his family joint demino
it's amazing
it's Little Caesars yes Little Caesar
it's a nice place homemade just ask for
the Gerald
no I ate too much because I was trying
to replenish and it was it was like the
Apollo 13 thing where I'm going like oh
my gosh do I have to like do I have to
slingshot around the Moon do I have to
keep going in order to come back and I
overdid it oh so here we are and uh you
know I'm 11 fastest man on his feet
quickest what in the west Dave Linda
Ahoy you have a better weekend than
Gerald I I did I was in uh
uh Ohio oh
yeah that's where I was the midwestern I
forgot it was good it was great a lot of
fun fans a lot of good people yeah and
uh they love you and good and they love
Gerald that'll be fun where we'll uh
we'll now discuss the worst people among
us here when we discuss not only John
Oliver but a few other things so the
people who agreed with the uh John
Oliver were not at this year no no I
can't imagine thank God no they were in
the uh the ward no they were wait wait
yeah so I don't even know this it's 20
22. and uh you know women because of
2022 the year changes biology women are
not the only ones anymore who can get
pregnant
now if you think that a man getting
pregnant is weird if you think it's
weird you're a bigot
can we skip to the good part
you've arrived at your destination
[Music]
well I just want to die
you have to do the home birth to be
extra weird about it yes do they do the
dolphin birth where they go out in the
ocean like the Dolphins will give you
everything and my son has got your child
yes so oh boy you've seen the home birth
where they just do it standing and like
squatting in their house and it's like
could you move you're blocking the team
yes
I want to end I want to kill myself when
I see how far we've gone but I can't I
don't want to sell you the good name of
us so can someone bring me something at
some point any any way in which to uh
terminate myself uh that doesn't Sully
the name of a good spot that is not a
wolf we'll find a good point yeah you
need a good anything else because
they're true blue but I want to die
I feel bad for that child yes yes you
feel bad for that child the child looks
like like a happy like normal lovely
child but there is going to come a day
where that is going to be a molested
sorry I know I I'm just saying that
that's that's just gonna be a really
weird hard position to be in I love that
we blurred the nipples though I know I
did too I was like oh thank goodness I
didn't want to see that and I'm going to
be honest with you because we don't
really know the rules yeah on that you
have no idea
what do we blur let's just let's just
blur the nip all of it but Charles
Dickens would have wanted to see her
nipples name that movie line uh
you'll always win people will name it
below
this is what we were going to talk about
today uh because it was happening this
weekend
um but you've seen this clip we've moved
it to tomorrow because there's something
pretty thorough I want to address but
here's the clip for those who don't know
creepypetto former Vice President Joe
Biden being what he be
okay
now very important thing I told my
daughter and granddaughters you no
serious guys you were 30. okay no what
no serious guys to your 30s
me so everyone's talking about how
creepy it is and of course if you're a
father who would let someone uh treat
your daughter that way you probably are
I mean just you should give up your
child to me I would rather you give them
to the male of the Z is going to say let
me go back to that yes Alec cleanser
yeah but there's something there that is
far more severe and I think far more
impactful uh than just him lightly
groping her comment below if you see
what it is because we're gonna address
it tomorrow
I think people are missing the macro
picture there
um which it's for the girls it's this
one's for the girls tomorrow show is for
the girls the there we go some of the
some of the uh I'll just okay it's the
advice spoiler alert
I don't know how to there's only one
phrase so you guys know what the phrase
I thought you're going to be like the
Secret Service guy going hey make sure
that guy doesn't record it anymore oh
gosh Joe's going off script he's talking
about girls again that's always a good
sign if the secret service has it on
their bullet point checklist to make
sure no one's filming if he gets around
a young girl
just get the camera gross it's like for
you know president Trump they'd be like
let's keep him off of Twitter because
they get with Joe Biden like keep him
away from children
well yeah they're not they're not even
going for the grope they're going for
the phone yeah exactly Trump had a
burner phone for Twitter yeah exactly
I'd be using in the bathroom he'll never
find my Cricket
I have Boost that Travis Barker really
makes a good case now is this boost
still a thing it was amped in boost I
have no idea I don't even know where you
get that you should be at the kiosk at
the mall is that where it was remember
yeah maybe like you get all the same
benefits except for Speed except for
texting except for calls I always keep
my head down and pretend I'm deaf
because they try to talk to you yeah
like no no no no no you're not a person
yeah exactly when you walk through the
mall and they where they go hey what why
aren't you talking back to us because
this isn't a street vendor in Iran okay
this is not okay
trying to go to Yankee Candle Store I
don't want to have a Carnival Barker I'm
already having a hermit crabs and spider
Marvel painted shells yeah she knows the
hermit crab exhibit where they have all
the different painted shells no oh yeah
that's great
you actually stopped and what like oh
this is cool oh I've owned a few hermit
crabs do you have She-Hulk yeah
that's better than bedazzled phone cases
let me see what kind of phone you have
it's like
no
that's the guy filming Joe Biden with
the girl you hear the crunching of the
rhinestones
falling off let me see if I can waste
more of your money here buy this one
okay so this one is in Gerald's
wheelhouse so again before we get to
John Oliver it's going to be a pretty
long rebuttal here today because I I
just wanted to focus I was fired up this
morning a little bit before that this is
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers Tampa Bay
Buccaneers the coach Todd bull set it up
for me so the Tampa Bay Buccaneers head
coach Todd Wells he's he's he's black oh
yeah so he's a black head coach in the
league which there's not a whole lot of
those and he's being asked some
questions by reporters after playing
against another black head coach uh
Tomlin in uh Pittsburgh yes and then he
gets white-splained by a female reporter
yes oh have you seen this I I I've never
seen anything more patronized yeah it's
it's really you're gonna have to watch
some of this through your fingers but
just keep in mind this is what the left
believes and occasionally it slips here
it is you you and Mike Tomlin are two of
the few blackhead coaches in the league
I wonder what your relationship is like
with them and your thoughts on Steve
Wilkes joining that bowl
I have a very good relationship with
Tomlin we don't look at
what color we are when we Coast against
each other we just know each other I
have a lot of very good white friends
that coach in this league as well and I
don't think it's a big deal as far as us
being coaching against each other I
think it's normal so we'll follow up
from another reporter the job hopefully
he does it and we coach ball we don't
look at color
you also understand that
too right and that went young coaches or
even football players wear Merit doesn't
mean anything
grew up like them that has to mean
something well when you say you see you
guys and look like them and grow up like
them means that we're eyeballs to begin
with and I think the minute you guys
start stop making a big deal about it
everybody else will as well
[Music]
let me try what she should have said was
she was they talk about white splitting
she's going you do realize that
representation matters like as a black
they hired you because you're a black
sheep let me try and put this in ways
you cannot maybe you can understand hey
you know man you were high because
you're black right because the coaching
the coach's representation do you agree
and his what he really want to say was
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
well thanks for letting me know white
[ __ ] I appreciate it
you're gonna be really happy to find out
that a lot of the players are black yes
yes yes well that's what they say
they're like oh the ownership's just
keeping black coaches out because they
don't like black people I'm like have
you looked at the roster oh yeah there's
a lot of people on that roster that are
not white and that's perfectly fine with
them yeah it's like you think that Larry
Bird called the
Bill ampere that's it yeah
and black guys loved it they were like
oh he was hard to guard just because he
would talk all this trash Oh so instead
of Bill land beer yeah part of the bad
boys they're just a complete you just
talk about how rich his dad was and piss
people off can we acknowledge genetics
as it relates to you know as it relates
racially when it comes to athleticism
like there's a the better it's black
people tend to be very good at a lot of
these sports that's in right it's a
meritocracy exactly Dominicans seem to
be way better at uh baseball than
anybody yeah well that's often because
they're like dead places them in a
closet and beats them for weeks on end
as well you know hey whatever it works
yeah
you mean the Tiger Woods strategies did
you understand that representation
matters and this is going to bring us
into the John Oliver thing it is largely
white women unfortunately white women
who are pushing this crap what happened
to take a backseat and listen to black
women because when it relates to trans
issues as it relates to sports issues
guess what they don't share the same
opinion as a lot of white women that is
everything that is wrong with America is
what she just said yes he represents
he's one of three black head coaches in
the league right now or there's two at
least and I think she mentioned somebody
else said joining the fold I think he
got another head coaching job three and
you just told the guy who should care
about this the most what he should think
about it right he told you like I kind
of feel like you guys are making a big
deal out of something that we don't
really think a whole lot about and
you're like oh no no no you're not in
any position to understand what this
means for somebody's like I'm the black
head coach in the NFL I'm the only
person in the room that can understand
what it means to be here and you're
telling me I don't yeah I've met a black
black head coaches and I like the NFL
and I didn't even know that statistic
until just now when she brought it up
right
we have a was it a new Harvard Harris
poll shows that only six percent of
Americans said that race relations were
a priority issue and it's usually a
priority issue with uh Suburban white
women yes they make up 5.9 of the six
percent yes
[Laughter]
if it's you know hey if it's if you're
colorblind it's racist uh and uh so
everything has to be about race what I
hated about that clip though she's
talking down to him like the tone in her
voice just you do realize that this
matters it's like no I don't I make a
lot of money because I worked really
hard to be here you realize that racial
representation is like oh oh can you
repeat that I'm I'm sorry I'm sorry
Master I don't understand yeah
she's like you know
yeah like is this better for you [ __ ]
it's better if you want me to start
reciting lasting the help oh
I would just love for a guy to do that
because you know that's what he's
thinking oh of course this [ __ ] well I
just love that he holds his head which
is the best nephew he's like oh
he's like I just said it yes I just
answered his question and let me just
point out he did it very calmly but he's
like and you said you guys and those
people and grew up like them uh
did you hear yourself say that
if I was any other person I'd be like
what you guys and how did I I grew up in
Bel Air what are you talking about lady
did he no no but who knows I mean she's
guessing because black he grew up poor
in rural Alabama like that I don't know
right like come on all right uh okay
let's move on to here John Oliver
um okay so a couple things that I want
to touch on here
this there's going to be an underlying
theme here that you'll see recurring uh
namely that when we're talking about the
transgender issue and particularly as it
relates to children they told you that
it was a slippery it was a slippery
slope logical fallacy ironically because
there are many logical fallacies
presented here today from John Oliver uh
when we said they're going to be
targeting children here it is they are
there's no doubt about that and they're
trying to Gaslight you so the two themes
I want you to see here and keep in mind
is gaslighting you're crazy why do you
care so much about this issue that
affects such a small percent of the
population as they try to push
legislation that would affect every
member of the population and the idea of
the empirical versus the anecdotal this
is really important because we just came
out of the era of trust the science but
here they ignore all of science
at the right instead they decide to give
the right-of-way to the anecdotal I
encourage you to go and watch the entire
video it's available on YouTube gets a
lot of heavy promotional dollars right
when John Oliver does these things it
gets FL it gets pushed everywhere if you
search Stephen Crowder rebuttal John
Oliver you'll see John Oliver's segments
and you won't see ours
so um I want you to keep in mind
empirical versus anecdotal the idea of
gaslighting because we are dealing with
narcissists we are dealing with people
who believe that whatever makes them
feel good and largely that's Praise of
their constituents must be right makes
me feel good it's about how I feel and
they falsely equate that with happiness
and narcissists seek control
and narcissists seek to make you think
that you are crazy
so that that way all of their behavior
is permissible and no one actually calls
them to the mat so let's keep that in
mind with John Oliver as we go through
this point by Point uh Sunday October
17th
he released another segment this is a
second segment on what he presents as
transgender rights and by the way they
say transgender rights are human rights
let me make sure just so you know where
I'm coming from here as it relates to
Children specifically transgender rights
what they present are not human rights
their atrocities that are being
committed these are sacrifices of
children
at the altar of narcissism
okay now if you disagree feel free to
comment on any of the claims that we
rebut below so let's go through it Claim
by claim
here is one that he makes as we lead it
off where he tries to tell you that what
is so why do so many people care about
an issue that affects so few people even
12 states have signed into little
anti-trans bills doesn't tell you what
the bills are so here's a claim that he
makes right now about anti-trans bills
to try and set it up as though you're an
extremist let's go it is clearly more
than just bad jokes this year alone over
a hundred anti-trans bills have been
introduced in state houses and 12 states
have signed or enacted them with all of
this happening against a backdrop of
violence and threats including attacks
and harassment aimed at hospitals
providing gender affirming care to you
okay so that's the claim let's get to
the truth here again the empirical he
just says 12 states do we know does John
Oliver make his sources publicly
available is can you go to HBO and see
probably not okay yeah so that app all
of ours yes no I mean how many salon and
slate links do you need
so let's look at some of these so-called
anti-trans bills all of our references
are available Link in the description
Arkansas they passed the save the
adolescence from experimentation act
okay safe for short let me read it to
you the new law bans the user
descriptions bans the use of puberty
blocking drugs on minors and also
prohibits surgical interventions
including breast reductions now most of
you would say including if you're a
Democrat that sounds reasonable
and of course if this is why would they
why would this even need to be presented
because as a baseline we would all agree
that you shouldn't have surgical
procedures being conducted as an
experiment on children who don't have
the ability to consent to even sex let
alone decisions that affect their sexual
life for all
all of eternity uh I don't know in the
afterlife so I don't want to that's how
they come back it may it may I have no
idea it grows back got a little joke but
here's the thing the reason they had to
present that bill is because of the
kinds of pushes that you see from John
Oliver case in point Rhino Governor
there the Rhino Governor what's his name
what's the Hutchinson Hutchinson yeah
Hutchinson attempted DeVito this bill
but the veto was overridden in passing
the law which proves the necessity of
the bill in the first place the reasons
they need to create a bill that he says
is an anti-trans bill which specifically
bans the use of puberty blocking drugs
on minors and surgical interventions
that's the anti-trans bill remember we
went from Target won't let them take a
[ __ ] in the bathroom they want and it's
just like the it's just like the
pre-civil rights era now it's you can't
give puberty blockers or cut off a penis
of a six seven fifteen-year-old it's an
anti-trans bill and the governor tried
to veto it which shows you the reason
for the bill in the first place let's go
to Oklahoma uh Governor Stitt signed the
save women's sports act athletic teams
designated for females women or girls
shall not be open to students of the
male sex why did that bill for that
because it was happening yeah it's been
happening across the country Virginia uh
you see their new education policy says
that students shall use bathrooms that
correspond to his or her sex except to
the extent that Federal Law requires
years otherwise you can go look at all
these bills that he presents as just
anti-trans bills again the attempt there
is to Gaslight you're going well I'm not
anti-trans because you're not a bit I
don't hate hold on a second I wouldn't
support those bills because you probably
believe that it's Banning trans people
from public forums
these are very specific bills that were
required precisely because of the kind
of push that John Oliver makes by the
way it's a live show here Monday through
Thursday 10 a.m Eastern no idea how long
we'll be on YouTube especially this this
is the third rail so tune in hit the
button there yeah nothing will make me
more happy than all of you going over to
rumble or Mud Club and one of the things
look at every one of the the Common
Thread through each one of those things
playing sports School restrooms right
these are people who are kids right I'm
not talking about adults here doing this
stuff in their 30s or 40s or 50s and
making this kind of a decision in their
life we're talking about a 10 year old
coming to their parents and saying I
identify this way and wanting to use a
different bathroom and wanting to plan a
different sports team these are kids
that they're experimenting with and
they're actively saying that this is a
good healthy productive actively
promoting it and trying to shut down any
debate yeah before it happens so here's
a case in point the next claim he goes
on to accuse conservatives of
demagoguing uh and sort of appealing to
emotion and then John Oliver immediately
uses and I mean uses exploits a child to
appeal to your emotion in the absence of
the empirical let's also remember that
it's not actually the left talking about
trans rights non-stop it's Republicans
who see an advantage in demagoguing this
issue and to ignore them doing that is
to allow them to have real calamitous
impacts on people's lives a few years
ago voice profiled a girl named Kai
shapley and just watch how happy she is
talking about her hopes for her future
until she remembers something that
changes it and this has not been
scripted or this girl culture
yeah what would you change about the
world if you were president
chance people be free and go to the
bathroom they want to go to
are you able to use the girls bathroom
at school
[Music]
no they just put security guards up
oh I hate that that is brutal it is so
dark it's genuinely hard to watch let me
change one thing here before we get to
the truth well I do agree with that part
yes yes it is very good yeah uh let me
change one thing before we get to the
truth here's uh ask that child
about anything else regarding policy if
they were president and would you take
it seriously of of course not but you're
supposed to take it seriously when this
I believe boy who's transitioned to a
girl at that age uh says I would make it
so that we could use any bathroom we
want and John Oliver takes it as
legitimate if you ask them about foreign
policy if you ask them about immigration
policy but I don't know anything they're
a kid kids are stupid when it comes to
permanent life-altering decisions
yeah why why would you care what they
they don't know do you think all Pizza
should be free on Tuesday yeah well
there you have it we have to have Little
Caesar's day every day do you like going
to bed on time I hate that oh look how
she changed we're gonna do away with
national curfews you here first yep all
the ice cream you can have on Saturday
yep yeah and it's free I love by the way
yeah I love that he went to her first
because we'll come back to her later on
when she's 11 years old speaking so
she's ten nine potentially there that's
what you want John a nine-year-old
making these decisions or a ten-year-old
making these decisions and by the way
when you said look how happy she is I
don't know that anybody in the room that
saw that would go bubbly happy playful
more like
no because he lost it you're just trying
to set it up like she's happy then she
becomes sad and it's like that's not
what we just saw no that's not what we
just saw that's not what we just saw
really a security guard like if she's
walking into the girl's bathroom he was
like hey hey stop
dead naming
throwing her against the wall right
that's what they were so here's the
truth by the way too the empirical here
are the some of the statistics on child
outcomes uh for decades there have been
follow-up studies of transgender
children they've shown that a
substantial majority anywhere from 65 on
the low end to 94 eventually completely
cease to identify as transgender wow
okay and if you uh don't enter so if you
basically if you don't intervene they
all grow out of it if you do intervene
that number goes down to some study show
as low as zero percent and by the way
the child conversion rate has increased
by over four thousand percent in the
last decade especially among young girls
I get it correlation doesn't equal
causation but we'll get to that in a
second
that's also a lot faster than the adult
transition rate just to be clear and
saying a lot faster is a very mild way
of putting it in it's almost all
happening with kids yes four thousand's
a lot yeah four thousand percent
increase well they want you to believe
it's because now they're more free
because before they were being oppressed
worse than uh American slaves because
they couldn't take a dump at the
gender-neutral bathroom in Walmart so
the this is what caused the major
depression for the kids and what will
fix it is injecting them with estrogen
so let's go on to the next claim that
John Oliver makes and again these are so
pernicious it's just it is I would I
would say it's evil when you are saying
that children should be making these
decisions and you are trying to strip
the rights of parents who believe not
who believe who understand the science
that it's not good for children to
fundamentally alter their hormones or
make permanent decisions regarding their
sexual capabilities so here's another
claim that he makes that conservatives
have nothing else to worry about that
you're crazy because you're just making
it you're making a mountain out of a
molehill uh with the whole trans athlete
thing 18 states have laws aimed at
protecting Youth Sports and South Dakota
Governor Christie gnome even made her
State's Bill a centerpiece of a campaign
ad now Governor gnome has a bill that
will give South Dakota the strongest law
in the nation protecting female sports
okay if you time traveled here from the
past and the first thing you saw was
this ad you would think two things one
wow the campaign centers around Youth
Sports I guess literally every other
problem in America has been solved and
two she is not pulling off that cowboy
hat
yeah also if you're an alien biologist
who came here to Earth you'd be like oh
we are not able to understand how they
reproduce with between the male and they
were just short circuit yes
so here's the truth I kind of like the
cowboy hat I like the cowboy hat as well
yeah I'm gonna be honest it makes me
very comfortable it played the truth is
this is what we call a reverse Nirvana
fallacy okay it's an intellect let's
bring up the logical fallacy alert
a lot of these are used with a bit of at
home and I'm thrown in so let me read
you the reverse Nirvana fallacy it's
comparing a realistic solution with an
idealized one in discounting or even
dismissing the realistic solution as a
result of comparing it to a perfect
world or impossible standard so in this
case we also have basically well since
it hasn't become a huge problem yet why
would you do anything about it well
first off that's not exactly true it's a
much bigger problem than John Oliver
lets on second it hasn't necessarily
been a problem yet because the radical
progression the radical anti-science
progression stripping parents are the
rights hadn't been enacted by [ __ ]
like you yet
doesn't mean that it can't happen and
the solution is not to do nothing about
it let me give you some examples here
Connecticut this is one of my favorite
pictures of all time uh there were two
trans athletes who actually ended up
winning uh the race in Connecticut human
I think it's overlay A6 uh there was 100
meter and 200 meter these were records
in the event overlay A6 there uh tokeno
yeah just give me a minute okay
um and all these references will be
available later with credit.com because
I have to kind of go along pretty
quickly so you have that you remember
the true transgender athletes breaking
the finish line
let's find that picture guys the two
trans athletes breaking the Finish Line
in Connecticut and then one girl like
trailing far behind then of course you
can Leah Thomas was nominated as the
NCAA woman of the year after winning the
550 meter freestyle this affected Other
Women of course they're scholarships
their ability to get a spot uh on uh on
College rosters or their ability to
qualify for World Championships you have
Fallon Fox who broke an opponent's skull
orbital bone lived lived her life as a
man until 30s and I believe bothered
children oh wow
then you have cycling you have Rachel
McKinnon set a world record at anything
about the situation I'm laughing at the
absurdity of Fallon Fox who lived as a
man until 30 something years old
breaking a woman's face yes yeah and
this is the one time you care about
cycling in the history of the world yes
[Laughter]
examples internationally in New Zealand
Olympic weightlifting they're they're
examples now it doesn't affect largely
white women so white women don't really
care about it because many white women
don't compete in sports you don't see
the same opinions by the way with most
women minority women I don't know what
happened to listening to them yeah it's
white women exclusively not you if
you're listening you're perfect
uh who have largely spearheaded this
under the guise of wanting to be
compassionate it comes from a good place
it's got to stop so we have these
examples that have happened she's
leading bikes hold up pull up this
picture that's half a mile down the
other way they didn't even want the ones
to be blurry in the photo they couldn't
get one without it the only way it could
be more severe is if like you just had a
picture of Usain Bolt and like the Greek
national team yeah yes
so these are the examples that have
happened and then of course you have a
previous piece by John Oliver the media
sound like former Vice President Joe
Budden it's not a joke give me a kid I
need to replenish right as rain so just
so yes like a poddling
um there were so many examples and there
was such an aggressive push that now in
the Olympics by the way you just have to
prove that you've been on hormone
blockers for one year and there isn't
even a testosterone cap not an official
one it'll be delegated to the sports
so remember it started with well if
you're legitimate transsexual at least
you have transvestites and transsexuals
transvestites were people who dress like
women transsexuals are people who went
through the operation now I've added
transgenders where you can compete in
the Olympics without a testosterone cap
without ever having actually gone
through the transition and beat the hell
out of women that's the new policy of
the Olympics hit the like button if you
think that's [ __ ]
by the way this in the homosexual
marriage the gay marriage bill
everything else when there's an easy
obvious solution to the problem and you
choose to make it as painful as possible
and as illogical as possible you know
you're just pushing an agenda that's all
that's going on here if you wanted to
compete if men people who were born men
I'm sorry women who transitioned into
men uh wanted to compete they could do
that men more importantly that
transition into women in competing
women's sports you can make a division
for them go and compete and be the very
best in that category why are we trying
to make it difficult yeah how do you
feel about performance enhancing drugs
in sports
because the advantage that a man on
steroids would have over another man is
not is infinitesimal compared to what
the advantage that a male hormonal
profile would carry against any woman
it's not even close the walking human
pin cushions from Russia are not even
close to what a man enjoys as far as an
advantage over female athletes you know
it we know it let's stop lying as though
we don't all know it yeah well exactly
Russia actually disbanded their entire
program of steroids and just
transitioned all their male athletes yes
exactly in all the gold medals oh nice
okay here this way that's fair we have
uh Yanko emilianenko oh that is not
correct I am now Cindy
all right
it's just full beard somebody should do
this I swear a country an enterprising
country they are it's called United
States of America well that's true
that's true they just do it be like all
right we own all records now I would say
I am for performance enhancing drugs in
sports though it really made baseball a
lot of [ __ ] non-contact Sports yeah
yeah how about this how about clean mail
contact Sports
clean female division yeah and then you
have an all other gender any performance
financing drugs let the games begin yeah
all right could you imagine golf just
the rage
skirt they have to blur six inches
beneath it
and he lines up for the Putt and oh gets
Tangled in his cockpitter
that's tough when that happens she's
taking home the trophy it's a set of
balls yes of course we know that Tower
athletes are allowed one piece of
athletic tape
do not constant advantage and this was
used on the left side of his upper thigh
uh not quite enough put it on with the
right side not a bit of sweat has held
to the second hole
and here's how we know we're dealing
with narcissists in the gaslighter okay
what they try and do is accuse you of
doing exactly what they are doing and I
do mean this a progressive it's it's an
it's a movement of narcissism
it's all about what makes you feel good
and then that's misconstrued as
happiness and you'll see him do that
later they want to accuse you of doing
what it is that they're doing so right
here John Oliver here's another claim he
takes issue with Republicans renaming
things to make them sound like exactly
what they are
branding the discussion of trans issues
under the umbrella of radical gender
Theory and he tweeted out that
conservatives should start using the
phrase trans stripper in lieu of drag
queen it has a more lurid set of
connotations and shifts the debate to
sexualization and sure anything can
happen have a more lurid and sexual set
of connotations if you just rename it
okay so a couple things here's the truth
again they're cast on You by changing
language this is what they do they say
you want you want to change language
like mostly peaceful protests
like no evidence of widespread things
that we can't discuss but you said was
the greatest issue facing our national
security pre-2016 election you change
the language and by the way in this case
I don't have a problem with drag queen
because it's hypersexualized anyway but
what if they are transgender and a
stripper it's more descriptive well I
think they're trying to hide behind drag
queen and say you know this is somebody
in a dress who's just dressed as a woman
right who happens to be born a male
right that's not what's happening when
we saw all these drag queen stuff it was
people with lingerie type stuff on it
was people with really short skirts it
was people with their butt hanging out
like we saw the one in church they were
doing this in church and the girl comes
walking down the aisle I use that term
loosely and you could see you wouldn't
have a normal
Born This Way woman dressed like that in
church no it's like a seat wasn't
getting hot right no you're right they
could be a stripper they're probably not
literally a queen right that's a good
example yeah yeah although actually you
can technically buy uh I think you can
buy a small piece of land in Scotland
and you're a lord is that true really I
know it because I'm a Lord oh can you
show me I got it as a gift I own one
square foot of land in Scotland so I am
a Lord but I don't believe that those
drag trans strippers are queens now
that's one thing I will say I cannot
fully substantiate it not on your land
no well certainly not they're not
allowed no I believe in property rights
so
let's move on to another claim there's
so much to get to here today and uh by
the way uh share if you can that's what
helps with these algorithms on YouTube
and they do not want you to see this the
John Oliver video will be thrust into
every single person's timeline whether
you want it or not and of course it's
not even age restricted because that's
the goal so another claim that he makes
is uh and what they try and do is take
one example
and say this is your entire argument
so John Oliver goes on to site one and
from what I understand a bit flawed
study about the role of peer pressure
increasing the rates of you know sort of
childhood transitioning but tries to
make it seem as though that's the only
study or the only empirical evidence
then we have even though it's not true
but this is how he presents it the rise
in kids identifying as trans is due to
social contagion that it's just a mass
delusion a trendy fad that is rapidly
spreading among young people destroy
sometimes dresses her argument up by
using the term rapid onset gender
dysphoria which is total it comes from a
study published by a researcher in 2018
hypothesizing that some kids identify as
trans due to peer pressure but it's
worth you knowing that study was based
on a survey of parents not actual trans
kids and targeted parents from
organizations dedicated to opposing
trans ideology which is instantly
disqualified okay so before I move on to
the truth of addressing that they are
it's again they're accusing you of what
they do saying which is told total
horseshit the description of Rapid onset
gender dysphoria how could you change
how could you add to gender dysphoria
hold on a second what happened from the
dsm-4 to the DSM-5 gender dysphoria was
classified as a disorder in which
someone believes that they are born to
the wrong sex wrong gender then they
changed it because of political pressure
to say gender dysphoria is actually a
description of the symptoms of somebody
who was born the wrong gender so we just
we just changed the definition of gender
dysphoria medically speaking with no new
empirical data to justify it and this is
a problem with many people who work in
the cycle uh the community of psychology
and Psychiatry not to mention people who
actually work in endocrinology but of
course trust the science by that I mean
fauci thrown out the opening pitch
here's the truth it's not just one study
that exists as far as this new
phenomenon of children transitioning at
record rates you've seen a dramatic
increase in surgery sex the sex
resignment Market in the United States
right now is valued at 1.9 billion in
the United States alone
expected to grow about 11.23 per year
from 2019 to 2020 a 15 increase in chest
surgeries for Trans males by the way
that outpaces almost and I say almost
just because I'm not entirely sure I
haven't had time this morning I'm
willing to bet all other elective
cosmetic surgeries yeah well and even
when I mean I know we don't love this
guy all the time but sometimes he makes
a point that we actually go huh that's
Lucid thank you no no you Dave Bill
Maher uh you're actually funny Bill Bill
Maher is not at all not even remotely
and he even came out back in May when I
think the New York Times released some
uh polling and for not polling study
information on this that says
transgender stuff is just blowing up
especially amongst the youth and not so
much among older people he said yeah I
understand that maybe people are a
little bit more free to talk about it
and there's some Freedom there that's it
contributing to that number he goes but
why is it so much so in California
versus Ohio say like it's this trendy
fad yeah it's a dramatic difference in
the Locale geography matters a whole lot
and I know we'll talk about that in a
second but when Bill Maher is at the
point where he's like hold on guys yeah
what are we doing here like you really
need to stop and take a look at your
argument because John Oliver all he did
was say it's only because of Freedom
it's only because they can now do this
stuff and not be and the only example
pointing out this might be a problem is
this one flawed study no it's not only
study after study after study after
study which we'll get into mental health
issues we'll get into the likelihood of
not only likelihood the verifiable not
only mental health but physical health
health as it relates to cancer issues
these are all documented not to mention
the statistics of children who
transition if there is no intervention
versus if there is all of that is
documented we're also talking about the
economic data that we have in relation
to surgeries being performed we're
talking about the data that we have from
whether it's a Census Bureau or a local
state sort of polling institutions how
different it is regarding geography
regarding the politics of the parents
now you can say that haunts of the
chicken or the egg correlation is an
equal causation and maybe that's because
those kids are more free because they
were actually trans sure sure we can
have that nature nurture conversation
but only if you acknowledge that there's
a dramatic difference
he doesn't want to because he doesn't
want you to do the digging please dig
through the references that I provide
please go watch this whole video I beg
you please do the research all of it
that you can this is about the soul of
the country
it's about parents having the right to
make medical decisions for their
children which by the way is one of the
bedrocks it is the Bedrock of parental
rights looking divorce that's one of the
biggest issues that happens in divorce
court is who gets to make medical
decisions it's parents kids are never
left to make their own medical decisions
let alone one this severe
let's go on to another claim I don't I
don't think cosmetic medical decisions
in a lot of ways which I know that they
argue this wouldn't be but I mean you're
looking at something where it's not like
you're saying how it's you know because
of Freedom it's not legalized weed it's
permanent mutilation in a lot of cases
because if you change your mind on it
that's what it is to you yep it's it's
your permanent destruction of your body
he goes on to say well that's not really
the case it's mostly reverse
reverse sterility but it's a very small
Choice very small chance and children
have the right to make that yes because
they make informed decisions because
when you're seven years old you really
understand the full scope of a Barren
womb when you're 28.
you haven't even had a period I'm right
or understood an erection you're going
to tell me how that's disgusting I mean
I understood everything that I needed to
why
we had that tutor but
it was the She-Hulk card 4q man no it's
it's just it's so odd I mean even as a
teenager there's a reason like you can't
drink until you're 21 because you're
irresponsible you can't rent a car until
you're 25 because of all the synaps he's
having right they haven't finished it
they're like why can't why can't I get a
what you're selling a call until 25 yeah
because the insurance rates are like
nine times higher oh is that because I
used to but is she okay you know what
you're part of the Hertz Gold program
just get out of here yeah we might as
well just start letting big wheels on
the freeway yes what's the difference
I'm gonna take my business down to
Enterprise
fine
so here's another claim that he makes uh
that uh you know people merely exploring
their gender identity as though that's
all it is
why is that a bad thing you hateful
bigot and to the extent that some young
people are just exploring their gender
identity how exactly is that a bad thing
who the [ __ ] are they hurting themselves
yep so let's go through this uh a point
by Point statistically here's a truth
attempted suicide rate for transgender
individuals is uh somewhere around 40
percent
okay and by the way it doesn't get much
better pre or post-op it's always
between about 40 to 42 based on the data
that we have
so the idea that this transition would
help uh or fix it well the data doesn't
show us that
who are they hurting well there's an
answer for you it's good if you see a
therapist and he just flips a coin right
yes exactly well shouldn't have gone to
therapist to face
well uh it looks like you're going to be
prepay yes
[Laughter]
just so you know this is not covered by
Insurance yeah we're not billing you
that's okay should I come every Tuesday
oh I I doubt it let's wait till Monday
and just schedule for the next day
okay so we have this dramatically High
attempted suicide rate okay
you might say well honest I can pre and
post up the reason it's the same is
because of how mistreated they are for
that to hold water and there might be
something there of course that
transgender people feel ostracized I'm
not saying that they don't uh you would
have to compare it against the control
are there other groups that are
minorities that have been marginalized
and have their suicide rates uh been
comparable well gays it's seven to
twenty percent
blacks during slavery it's about 7.2
percent according to surgeon logs
in concentration camps about 25 so
you have to ask yourself is this suicide
rate pre and post-op likely due to
societal ostracization
or hold on a second maybe not because I
don't believe that current transgender
students in California have it worse
than Jews and Auschwitz or American
slaves
we have control after control after
control of people who experience the
worst conditions Beyond not being able
to leave a little curly three-ring
circus at the Target bathroom
wow has a curlicue we were just talking
about that yeah we were above water I
had again it was a putting tea it's
above sea level you know yes yes use the
tea to putt but I understand I
appreciate the effort
uh and yeah post-op transgenders still
also night to give you Scope 19 times
more likely to commit suicide than the
general population post-op transgenders
19 times more likely references post got
everything you want 19. got everything
you want you look like a woman you have
all the same rights you can compete
wherever you want to compete you're on
puberty blockers you've gotten the
estrogen that you want you've got the
whatever hormones that you want if
you're a woman to man testosterone and
the suicide rate is still a multiple of
Jews and concentration camps American
slaves and gays lesbians not to mention
of course every other racial minority
it's not even close I I can't tell you
the one other demographic where they
attempted suicide rate is so high
because the exact comparison might get
us removed from YouTube it will there's
only one other demographic that has this
same rate of attempted suicide well
reveal it in mug Club but do some
research won't be hard to find well it
would seem to the the attempted suicide
rate is up and this is speculation
um just judging by you know people in my
own family I guess but amongst uh
teenagers just in general and I would
assume that it has to do with a lot of
woke think probably when you're a
Perpetual victim and you believe that
everything is outside of your control
exactly that makes it hopeless or if
you're the person who they think is the
victimizer right either way it goes it's
bad because then you still have bullying
either way yeah one or the other that's
why I I have a I have an issue where you
say okay all these people in California
that are transgender kids are having a
tough time in school
how right yeah it's California squin
that's what it's being catered to right
is exactly who you are well here's the
thing no one's saying that there isn't a
isn't discrimination that occurs of
course at some level on an individual
level I'd say as far as systemic you can
give me an example if you want to say
systemic oppression but again
I think it's a good point when you talk
when you remove the tools of people
to deal with this
namely that there's some kind of
autonomy that you have some control some
say in your own destiny you create
hopelessness that's why even though the
conditions the treatment of American
slaves African-American slaves
absolutely horrible abort well not even
close to the suicide rate of people why
there were tools there was hope they
actually saw some kind of progress that
could take place it took a while we did
that for the rest of the world you're
welcome same thing with Jews and the
Holocaust think about it they felt as
though they had more hope than
transgender youth today in California
where the legislation that they want has
already been passed that tells you that
it's not just Society it's that these
people they they have been victimized by
you telling them that they are
perpetually victimized you are actually
the Predator uh which brings us to
another truth per the FDA by the way
Purity blockers can cause brain swelling
vision loss other kinds of psychiatric
issues here's something else that nobody
wants to talk about they say oh the
science is out on hormone replacement
therapy well not exactly here's another
the truth excess estrogen in the body is
of course believed to be cancerous now I
cannot say definitively 100 percent just
to be clear on YouTube that injecting a
boy with estrogen or altering his
hormone levels might actually prove to
be cancergenic because we haven't done
those studies yet because we've never
had to but men with high levels of
estrogen have had a multiple
increase in their odds of breast cancer
than men who have normal levels also
anyone out there women women right now
have you had breast cancer
I've had many people are survivors of
breast cancer in my family it runs my
family
what's the first thing they do
what's the first thing to do if you have
breast cancer or one of usually the
protocol immediately evolves in a what
they call an AI no not talking about
Skynet aromatase inhibitors
to try and slow the conversion to
estrogen because even with women we know
that excess estrogen
can increase the rate of metastasization
so we even with women say the first line
of defense is let's try and reduce
excess estrogen in the body the science
isn't on that that's what they do that's
a scientific protocol same thing with
men excess estrogen levels go and get
your hormone levels checked when
injected directly into the thigh of a
seven-year-old however we don't have the
long-term studies therefore let's make
it the Wild West
shouldn't the we don't have the
long-term studies be we need to wait
until we have the long-term studies how
many times are we going to do this
injecting things into people without
long-term studies and no I'm not talking
about something that could get us banned
right well you know why you know why
they don't want to because it would be a
complete violation of medical ethics to
even try and conduct a long-term study
because of based on what we already know
you could not find a clinic or a doctor
in clear conscience to say yeah let's
see what happens with these kids we
inject with estrogen versus the control
group it would be a violation of the
Hippocratic Oath
so instead let's just make you Society
of the experiment it's not like we've
done that any other time by the way Dave
and I uh on tour here we have uh some
dates left uh at the University of
Nashville November 12th we added a
second show at the Ryman Auditorium the
original Grand Ole Opry 9 30. there's
that second show some tickets there and
then Baltimore December 3rd lotto's
credit.com I think those are the only
shows with tickets left yes uh jersey
sold out and yeah we've got the lyric in
Baltimore that's as close as they'd let
you to DC yes they would just yes I
apologize pictures up on walls
everywhere there you can't get in if you
want to see us in that General
Mid-Atlantic area you have to live out
your wire fantasies yes
all right let's go on to the next claim
sir there's so much here but all the
references are available I think again I
think this is more important than taxes
um
they're trying to uh well let's just go
just show his next client notably young
people are showing up in public forums
where adults are feeling hungry about
letting trans kids into Youth Sports and
bathrooms and try to talk some sense
into them I will not let a board full of
people who barely represent me tell me
who I am and what I can do grow up and
fix your behavior the leader of the My
Chemical Romance fan club I'm worried
about if I'm gonna fail Spanish in my
next class you will use these bathrooms
repeatedly alongside trans people and
have never once felt threatened well
look at you I don't see those rooms just
got humiliated by teenagers as we all
know the most brutal form of humiliation
that there is wow he's walking human
clickbait got humiliated absolutely
smashed by this girl who shot this
assistant manager at all topic
is he watching a different clip than we
were nobody owned anybody in that clip
they just said no it's not a problem and
I'm like okay okay thanks you're
fear-mongering here are some anecdotal
examples of right largely white women
who don't care who don't compete in
sports who don't really have a dog in
this fight
oh you just got owned here's the truth
if we're going to go to the anecdotal
there are far more examples
of it being a problem than a few people
who speak at a Podium there guy
literally dressed as a girl sexually
assaulted a girl in Loudoun County
remember that then the father was
arrested because he was speaking out
against it because the school board
basically covered it up in in Brevard
County in Florida a gorilla accused a
trans female of groping her in the
bathroom
and by the way plenty of other girls I
think we have a clip have expressed
issues and fears and outrage at trans
bathroom policies what happened to leave
all women
being a girl is not all in my head boys
who identify as girls are no different
from boys who identify as boys
but boys but feelings are not why we
have separate bathrooms we have separate
bathrooms because of what our bodies do
in them
bodies matter
calling girls bigots because they don't
want to use the toilet in a stall next
to a boy or get undressed next to a boy
as cruel and wrong it is embarrassing
enough for a girl to change a pad
knowing all the other girls can hear the
critical of the packaging but telling
her that she must be okay doing it in
the presence of boys because their
preferred pronouns are she her how evil
can you be
notice even the difference in the way
that the the children who lean right and
the children who lean left argue she she
doesn't just to appeal to emotion she
says biologically they are the same that
is correct biologically they are the
same regardless of how they identify
yeah it is not something that just
exists in your head it is something that
takes place in the body that is
scientifically that is factually correct
the girls he presented said who are you
to tell me what I think we're not
telling you what you think we're telling
you that you're a young girl who can't
think straight and we're going to think
for you as we do in all other scenarios
with young girls and boys yeah and by
the way I don't care if you're
comfortable with it I really don't like
this one girl you bring up says well
I've used it next to transfers fine
you're comfortable with it now let's
line up all the girls who are not
comfortable with it just like this one
they don't forfeit their rights because
you have an uneducated opinion I'm fine
with blacks not being able to vote said
that reporter to that head coach yes
so why do you have a problem with it
well it doesn't matter
well the girl makes a very well educated
honest point and the other ones just
showed up like Cartman like I'll do what
I want I'm more concerned if I'm gonna
pass Spanish
I mean as you should yeah why
because I've been cheating I've been
cheating on Zoom all year and then
failed the acts record lows we'll get
into a segment by the way by the way uh
Spanish goal has to be trafficked
masculine and feminine uh uh words there
and yeah they still have it in Spanish
are you gonna still take it I don't know
if you should because it's it's just
binary yeah yeah there's no language
it's a language of love and sexuality
which is also male female only male
female gendered nouns from all the
romance languages boy I sure hope you
don't end up taking Latin don't worry
that's a dead language
it's a theme uh here's another claim
from John Oliver and this is this is
really important because he makes the
claim right before refuting himself must
be nice to live in a world where you
don't get called to the mat on anything
Ray tells you
so I'll just roll this and roll the clip
right after that children don't don't
worry children are not in they're not
eligible for any kind of medical
intervention
but to his song Tell it as soon as a
child declares themselves trans there
was an immediate irreversible surgical
decision undertaken and there just isn't
so let's break down exactly what gender
affirming care consists of be very clear
prepubescent children are not eligible
for medical interventions
and then immediately goes immediately
into talking about medical intervention
and advocating for it on a legislative
level this is what happens right after
that clip at the onset of puberty an
adolescent and their family might
consider puberty blockers hormones that
delay puberty and importantly if that
treatment is suspended then puberty will
resume meaning this is reversible think
of it like a pause button the thing you
can't do easily on the HBO Max app now
the next potential medical intervention
is usually hormone therapy which boosts
levels of testosterone or estrogen
opponents of gender affirming care
about hormone therapy from saying that
it's experimental which it is not to
arguing that it sterilizes people and
look for some in specific situations
there can be risks to fertility but for
others the effect is anticipated to be
reversible if the medication is
discontinued okay couple of things this
is the he acknowledges that there
doesn't give you the actual severity of
it
um right it says experimental which it's
not hold on a second birth control isn't
considered experimental is it for
nine-year-olds
that's the [ __ ] he's pulling here of
course testosterone for people who are
older and I've talked about this I
advocate for it if you're older get your
hormones checked if you're in your 50s
your 60s and you're not feeling well yes
that is something which by the way
unfortunately the medical experiment
sorry the medical community in many
cases does consider it experimental
because we think it may have some
negative effects when you ask them about
estrogen injected directly into a child
however oh no no no no it's not
experimental yes it is there are plenty
of things that are not experimental for
adults that would be experimental with
children for the same reason they can't
smoke
for the same reason they can't consent
to sex with an adult
so let's also get into the truth here
many countries many countries have has
warned us about puberty blockers yeah uh
which I don't even know that I need to
get into this because he acknowledges
that it can cause sterility he says but
maybe but in many cases this can be
mitigated it's a if it's one percent
it's enough to say nope yeah by the way
he said uh it's anticipated that this
will be mitigated if you stop taking the
medication I'm like John you're quoting
something from 2018 from October 1st do
we not have any day any data between
October 1st 2018 and what is today
October 17th yes 2020 that's over four
years John that's a good question we
have a lot we have from Sweden we're
from the UK and then New Zealand just
sometimes it's the information that they
don't present they quietly remove the
description of safe and reversible what
from the Ministry of Health Website gone
now yeah I can't imagine that there's
any real proof that your puberty uh
would just start right back up as normal
oh yeah there couldn't be like years of
testing of this to actually know that I
just can't imagine like even if so could
you prove that it was the exact thing
right that it was supposed to be I don't
think that's possible no it's exactly
and the absence of what would be a
natural process you couldn't you can't
necessarily know what outcomes are part
of your manipulation right there's no
way yes Jeff Goldblum knew this yeah he
told me
there it is now also you should note
this is the problem
with the propaganda that comes from the
left is you have the John Oliver's there
they spout this nonsense and then I did
and you can go to a lot of credit.com
one of the advantages is everything
that's been banned from YouTube to the
tune of hundreds of millions of views
is available there
and I did a segment where I went
undercover at a Vermont town hall where
they were showing us how to get our
young children on puberty blockers and I
believe how to use Medicaid for it yeah
uh when we released that video on
YouTube and we actually refuted the idea
that they are completely reversible
without any health ramifications which I
cannot address here because of course
that got us into trouble they removed it
they removed it so that's no longer
available this is at a public town hall
mind you
they were telling you how to get your
children on period on hidden cameras you
can go watch it on a Mud Club just can't
see it on YouTube
so the facts are not allowed the science
is not allowed John Oliver's opinions
and the anecdotal is allowed that
changes perceptions that changes culture
that changes policy and it's a deadly
outcome yeah all right
let's go into another claim from him uh
oh this is another thing where it's just
to get an appeal to emotional fallacy
where he says uh you know no no kids are
just casually dropping in to get surgery
you bigot some things may be eligible
for instance for Top surgery or chest
masculinization medical intervention but
how many is that pretty rare it like all
of this would only happen after a team
of medical professionals discussed all
of its risks and benefits with their
patient and their patient's parent or
Guardian all of whom would have to sign
off no kid is casually dropping into an
operating room because they just decided
to get their uterus removed with
impulsive recklessness normally
associated with getting bangs yeah a
board of medical professionals like this
that's a huge [ __ ]
you think that person's going to be
unbiased who's openly said that they
want
to be uh more aggressive in
Interventional therapies that's the
first female five-star general you're
talking about they didn't even say woman
they said female star she's a biological
term and that but remember you were a
bigot if you said hold on a second I
don't actually I I think you're the one
changing gender and sex we used to use
them interchangeably oh you don't know
the difference between sex and gender
well apparently the former vice
president
Kamala Harrison the entire DNC and
Rachel Levine doesn't as well because
they refer to Rachel Levine as the first
female
not woman
you bigot why would you try and change
words
all right I'm a little pissed off at
Knowles for the way that he categorized
this and this is what led to John
Oliver's jumping off point saying oh you
can just walk in let's get this woman
right into surgery I'm like he kind of
made it easy for him Michael I know the
point you were trying to make but you
didn't make it in a way
that made a whole lot of sense what
really is going on here is he's saying
you guys will get together and you will
come up with this okay so we just talked
about the medical professionals being
pressured by their own agencies to make
sure that they offer gender affirming
care otherwise there could be some
ramifications down the line they didn't
say that but eventually that's what
happens right right parents they're
getting together with parents and
doctors to make decisions okay you mean
the same parents that you're saying if
you don't do gender affirming care that
you could possibly lose your children
that is happening in places around the
country right now people are talking
about that as being bigoted and hateful
yeah and reason enough for the state to
come into your home and start to do an
investigation of why you won't let your
14 year old transition how about Johns
Hopkins being suspended on social media
because they said that they wouldn't be
performing this care yeah or that's not
the suspensions just the Twitter just
the Twitter Facebook YouTube mob going
after what was a respected Medical
Institution yesterday now they're just a
bunch of quacks today believing that
penises are a thing yeah you've got two
groups of people that are being
bludgeoned into going along with this
and that's the triumvirate the person
who's making this decision and these two
other groups that can't speak out
against it for fear of being ostracized
from their job or losing their kids
those are the people John that you're
saying will get together and make an
informed rational decision right and by
the way it's also astronomy because
here's the truth from 2019 to 2021 uh
these are statistics from children ages
13 to 17 from Reuters there were 56
genital surgeries 776 mastectomies it's
pretty damn significant uh and then I
don't know if this is another claim from
yeah I think John Oliver right where he
says that the state shouldn't be
intervening
and this is where it comes to why do you
want to kill children all of us here we
want to kill children that's the only
reason we could
present the arguments or the thought
processes that we do the thought
processes that we do we don't care about
children we want to kill them by saying
ah maybe don't put children under the
age of well really children period on
puberty blockers perform sex
reassignment surgery unnecessary vanity
surgery that a kid doesn't really want
right
you meant to say I'm a child murderer
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what did I say
one
boy that was wordy I know just we're all
child murderers because we believe that
you shouldn't uh mutilate them and I do
mean mutilate here's the difference it's
only considered mutilation If the child
regrets it and we sound to people who
regret it which is a growing contingency
otherwise it's reassignment surgery so
here's another claim that he makes State
Should intervene because transitioning
children saves lives and there it is and
the Very notion that the state would
suddenly interfere in any of this is
understandably infuriating for both
trans kids and then yes you hate State
interference you socialist legislators
were Banning among other things hormone
therapy for young people describe what
it did for her son who suffered from
severe depression before transitioning
I'd say like a month to two months in I
started seeing that kid come back come
out of a shell talk to us more laugh
what did that feel like it was like
that's it this has this has been the
answer all along why would anybody want
to take that away from them there's no
reason why you should be butting in to
my care for my child what do you want to
say and exercise thank you
makes him feel good why would you want
to take that away from him for the same
reason that people might think it's a
good idea to take away your Funyuns
right
just because it makes you feel good
doesn't mean that it is doing good
Funyuns does the body good no no that's
milk
but it's a vegetable yeah there's a lot
of things it was a vegetable yeah at one
point in time you know what else oh man
you know what else on itself to
depression obesity oh obesity not only
as far as your endorphins but it also
becomes a vicious cycle people know this
as it relates to your insulin resistance
as it actually affects your hormones and
yes because a lot of people actually
understand this men who are often very
fat will suffer from low testosterone
high estrogen because if you look at
where estrogen convert converts so I'm
gonna say the conversion of testosterone
estrogen actually happens in the
presence of fat adipose tissue in other
words there are a lot of reasons that a
child may be depressed she has decided
it is because my child is the wrong
gender and Fu and she is the Pinnacle of
uh Parenthood yeah and I hate to say
this I have no idea what's going on this
situation I'm leaning towards what I'm
saying being true but there are a lot of
things that can make kids upset my son
wants to drink milk like it's going out
of style but if he does he'll end up
throwing up or he'll end up not being
able to sleep well his stomach will hurt
that's what being a parent is I can look
at yours desire right now and have the
ability with experience to say oh that
doesn't lead to a good place so let me
tell you so that you don't have to learn
the lesson the hard way except in this
case the parent just said oh thank God
something worked well but what about
four years from now what about five what
about one year from now for this child
with what you're doing for them helping
them in this moment you're taking these
short easy way out instead of saying hey
long term I've looked it up the studies
are terrible for this it's a 40 percent
suicide empirically she's wrong John
Oliver's wrong yeah well we left him in
his room is what we did and then we gave
him anything he wanted to eat yeah I
don't know why he was sad and the
Nintendos yeah so we gave him a vagina
and now he kind of talks to us yeah yeah
sometimes he talks through his vagina
like a lactose to senior Wednesday so
that's all right he'll be like what's
for dinner is it spaghetti again yep
hey don't play with that you need to go
do your dilator oh boy
and just to be clear I feel bad for
these children yes I have a problem with
the parents and I have a problem with
John Oliver and I have a problem with
the people who perpetuate doesn't have a
problem with I'm sorry the Suburban
female voters who don't stand up to your
friends in your circle this is the
reason it's happening men understand
that it's not good particularly it
relates to sports and black women and
Latino women do not support this
I broke a guy's hand at Golden Corral oh
dear yeah last day yeah you think you're
gonna get that last Salisbury I got
something for you yep send it right to
hell if you're going to go travel the
other one
who are they tell me if this is what
works well you know what your diet and
exercise regimen works right now until
two years from now when they have to
take off a foot and by the way again
it's sort of like yeah unfortunate with
diabetes I will say uh this isn't
necessarily medically true uh this might
be what is referred to as a joke uh you
just have to push past it because then
when they cut off your feet your BMI
resets yeah
and you lose weight it's like Apollo 13
you have to go around the Moon you got
to keep going to use the slingshot back
of fat
hit the like button by the way if you're
tired of this uh coming out from John
Oliver
I don't think you can have diabetes when
you're dead too so there's that yeah
well I well corpses are lighter cured
that's true they are later I go grave
Robin
oh I haven't I watched an episode of
lore with grave robbing and it was so
disturbing oh it really is it actually
happened in the UK oh were they anyway
that sounds sexy it's unrelated but it's
uh I'll talk it's how I get my jewelry
yes
claim that he tries to make again to
guilt you John Oliver is uh if you stop
kids from transitioning you
you are the one not the lady there who
maybe is actually making horrible
medical decisions that could negatively
affect your child for the rest of the
rest of the child's life you're the one
who's responsible for suicidal ideation
I Survey of around 28 000 trans people
found that of those who wanted hormone
therapy and didn't receive it 58
reported Suicidal Thoughts in a given
year which is why the three major
professional associations of Child and
Adolescent doctors psychologists and
psychiatrists have endorsed gender
affirming care and condemned efforts to
deny it okay so a couple of things here
let me get to a truth for you and this
is tough we have to sort of piecemeal
this why because we have some data on
transgender youth we don't have the
long-term data on transgender youth
again we talked about that reverse
Nirvana fallacy it's because no one
thought we had to study this because it
wasn't this kind of an issue so
trans youth are about three times more
likely to attempt suicide than non-trans
youth okay we don't have the long-term
suicide rates from transgender youth
post operation because there is no data
from that yet nothing reliable that I've
seen but we have three times more likely
transgender Youth and then we have the
fact that overall throughout their
lifetime post-op transgenders are 19
times more likely to commit suicide than
the general population by the way one of
those stats comes from Harvard
you can you can check out all the
references I highly encourage that you
do the the data is overwhelming here
sure you can say maybe a subset the
science is out and even then I would
argue no but the totality of it is
completely irrefutable it's why they
don't uh address it it's almost entirely
anecdotal from John Oliver I just lost
my he just threw it to the other side of
your head that man's mad with his pen
Clicker
and that someone threw it at you yeah
what happens I look like a direct hit it
was good
that's what would be now with home alone
uh you know when it's like his whole
fantasies he goes and eats nothing but
sugar right in the in the giant hotel
suite now it would just be double-sided
dildos yeah just and a sewing kit still
the sugar but his parents are there yes
it's just called Home Alone three
transitioning in New York yeah it's just
called home yes
laughs
oh Harry you're missing some balls my
goal my fake gold [ __ ] yeah
I'm a cow all right that's that kid
we're gonna break in and have consensual
sex with him yes
I don't think you can do that Harry what
are you talking about he can choose to
remove his uh remove his doctor when
he's six years old but he can the point
is it's a slippery slope it is it's dark
now next claim
from John Oliver is that he says uh
people uh and this is something because
there's a huge contingency and again we
don't really have all the data on this
uh because this hasn't all been studied
but every time we follow up on new
studies for example when people would
say that uh there was evidence of
different brains uh you know in
transgender individuals I can't remember
which study it was and there was a
Swedish study I believe it was the
remedy study that when they finally
actually looked at it and did a control
group of people and checked their brains
uh they actually did MRIs and checked
the sort of the neuros I don't know if
it was I know they checked the actual
frontal lobe portion of the brain maybe
someone can grab it gray matter they
wanted to see what was changed or what
was different with people who claim to
be transgender they found that the
changes when they followed up only
occurred after cross-sex hormone
replacement therapy this was a study
that was cited for a very long time I
said well hold on a sec we didn't
actually study them before they
underwent the hormone replacement
therapy let's let's create a new study
with a larger sample group I believe it
was a Swedish remedies study I can't
remember which one I'm going by wrote
here it's a while ago I said okay so
we're going to look at their brains
first look at their oh the changes occur
after we administer hormones which if
you understand the relationship between
hormones and uh neurotransmitters
they're very some people argue that
they're almost one and the same in some
instances so we don't have data on
everything but the data on people who
are detransitioning as it comes out is
alarming it's a very large percentage of
them
particularly children who transition
so he tries to cut that off with the
pass and silence people who have
de-transitioned saying the only reason
that they have like that lady with the
black coach the Buccaneers saying you do
understand that black people need
representation to a black man they're
trying to say right here John Oliver to
the women and men who've de-transitioned
you do know the only reason you're doing
that is because of social stigma right
here he is doing that [ __ ] and you
may have seen or heard from a small
subset of people who D transitioned but
it is worth knowing such cases are rare
and highly individualized studies show
an average of just two percent of people
who transition Express regret and that
the vast majority of those who have
opted to de-transition did so not
because of changes in their gender
identity but due to external factors
such as stigma and lack of social
support
okay remember we talked about if you
don't intervene with children the vast
majority of them grow out of it but if
you do almost none of them do
it's really hard to study that as the
point you know point that you made with
puberty blockers you don't know what
puberty would have looked like without
them even if you pause even if you stop
them right you can't know it's
impossible
and by the way something that uh sort of
anecdotal here but it's interesting and
I would love to see a comparison you see
it with a lot of people who compete in
Combat Sports particularly wrestlers who
have to cut weight I had friends who
were wrestlers and what happened one of
them was on dialysis because they'd have
to cut weight you go into college your
freshman year you have to wrestle let's
say at 182 and then you graduate you
still have to keep your spot at 182 when
they're consistently wringing out their
organs and some of them actually don't
go through puberty because of the damage
that that causes to their endocrine
system so imagine how much more severe
would be we don't some of them
afterwards have to get in hormone
replacement therapy for the rest of
their life the point is when you take
these drastic measures while you're
growing sometimes uh it is catastrophic
and it is permanent and it's very very
hard to study uh he also by the way goes
on to criticize these D transitioners
and uses uh what is he has an example
here let's just show I don't know the
next clip I'm going there's so many here
bear with me it's more [ __ ] I could
keep reading you stats and studies I do
after all love doing that
or I could just let you watch this boy
talk about what it felt like to have
someone actually see him for who he was
Dylan explained how as early as fourth
grade he'd had confusing feelings that
stretched on until his teenage years I
really wanted to cut my hair like really
bad and so when I did that that felt
really good and then I held the door for
somebody and they said thank you sir and
I was like oh yeah that yeah that this
little thing little thing uh sir put
words to how I was feeling and I was
like oh yep that that felt nice yeah
that's incredible no it's not
that's not incredible kind of rude sir I
have felt good this should be the basis
of our medical community that that young
Jake Paul look alike with thicker
eyebrows said it felt good to be called
Sir who are you to say otherwise a
doctor
not me but I'm saying hypothetically
yes there's a lot of things that don't
feel good I could present facts and
evidence and you know
actually I don't because you don't do it
you've been quoting from one study
saying there's no new information since
2018 but instead here's a young
transgender individual who says he likes
being called sir
let's be true oh yeah no better than
empirical data no it's just going back
to the original argument the emotions
food court yes exactly is this young man
at an Auntie Anne's saying that he likes
old windows
he's going to Lids now to get a baseball
cap done
nothing else to see here off to Spencers
to get condoms for his invisible [ __ ]
I'm one of those plasma orbs I love
those plasma orbs you cheeky plasma yeah
you know what would have been like the
more balanced approach to this is to
have somebody who's transitioned on and
say well well how do you feel now what
happened to listen to All Trans yeah
exactly they're only good because of
peer pressure
as opposed to kids who are transitioning
first because oh it felt really good
they said sir okay doesn't matter
it doesn't matter it felt really good
this is conflating the idea of what
feels good in the moment with happiness
they're not the same thing not at all
not the same thing guess what you may be
married you love your wife she's
fantastic it would feel really really
good for you in the moment to cheat on
your wife with the Dallas Cowboys
Cheerleader
doesn't mean that it's going to lead to
happiness yeah it's going to lead to a
miserable life it's going to lead to
guilt
it's going to lead to Calamity because
it feels good doesn't mean it's right
you're dealing with narcissists you're
dealing with narcissists and what they
what they seek is control like the
Meghan Markle like the Amber Heard it's
an entire party an entire ideological
wing of those people Gaslight you to
gain control accuse you of doing what it
is that they are doing and discount any
information or people who might question
whatever their truth is that's why they
use words that's why they use phrases
like speak my truth it's silly it's
nonsensical have you ever tried to break
that down that phrase speaking my truth
those words don't fit in that order in
that sentence well that's a just because
it's a lie yes exactly it used to be
called a lie yeah we've changed it and
now it's just well it was my truth ah
yes okay I wish I could chalk my way out
of a DUI with that here's my truth oh
you're gonna be in jail right your honor
of my truth was I was sober and did not
hit a pedestrian yes you are free to go
oh no no I understand where you're
coming from my truth is that's always
nothing more than club soda with lime
yeah exactly your honor I identify as
Trends oh sir please right this way it's
like you just put on the invisibility
cloak yeah awesome who's on trial I
can't even see you anymore you're free
to go it was a man worked for Caitlyn
Jenner yes how many hit and runs 19. all
references available a lot of questions
here's another claim which by the way is
I mean it refutes the earlier the clinic
he was trying to make about trans
individuals right if they're being
ostracized by Society he was talking
about how much more likely they're to be
depressed or attempt suicide so it's
kind of a half half rebutting of his own
claim but if you watch it he tries to
sort of BS his way out of it where he
says that trans people aren't any more
susceptible to depression than most
people
while opponents of trans rights will say
that these kids are either a menace or
brainwashed their Defenders will often
gravitate towards the same sad
statistics that I've shown you tonight
of depression and suicide and while that
is understandable on one level it's the
most devastating harm that can be
inflicted by these bills it's clearly
not the whole story which is that when
supported trans kids can experience full
vibrant lives because trans people are
not by default unhappier or more prone
to suffering than everyone else that is
something that we are putting on them
this is what and notice by the way this
is also something Dave made a good point
earlier about puberty and not being able
to study something when it's occurring
without in the absence of the natural
process yeah okay so you have Tran
here's what we know trans children far
more likely to experience depression far
more likely to uh attempt suicide of
suicidal ideation then we know that
transgender adults even post-op 19 times
more likely
the trick they pull is transgender
children right they're more happy after
they transition because they now go into
a new study group they're no longer
children
so it's a delayed it's a delayed effect
it's a fuse that's lit and then you say
hold on a second they're really
depressed right now before transition
most of them are happier after
transition what happens when they're
older than 18 years old we don't have
that data if you look at that data in
tandem guess what it gets worse it
doesn't get any better
but they're no longer a child so you can
have maybe a one two three five year
honeymoon period where they feel really
good and then they become one of those D
transitioners who John Oliver completely
discounts by the way as it relates to
depression 44 transgender people suffer
from clinical depression that's compared
to the United States in general about
8.4 percent that's what we call
statistically significant well and to
call them a menace for that that's the
part that I don't get he just put that
on people that are compassionate about
that it's like you think that we think
that they're a menace because they're
suicidal and depressed no it would be
the complete opposite right the complete
opposite Menace John and people like you
that won't dig deeply into what's going
on with these kids and just uses them as
a prop for your ideology yeah that's who
the Menace is in this situation look in
the mirror hey Mr Wilson she's dangling
from the porch
just doubt and kerosene
but that's like that he just throws that
at it's like you have no clip that says
anybody called them a menace right now
one person said they were a menace no
this is what you're not afforded the
benefit of that you just want to kill
transgender youth hey you know what I
don't want to put my uh my son or
daughter in a shallow cancerous grave
that's why I want to leave this world a
better place for my daughter my young
son
than it was before I came here and I
don't think the way to do that is to
inject them full of hormones
and most people don't most doctors don't
I guess you're going to apply pressure
and leverage and that's what's really
evil with this try and exclude people
exclude the voices exclude doctors
who say this is actually
this is actually medically it's
empirically a bad thing to do you're
just hateful
how can how can you call that progress
all right let's move on to the final
claim here uh from his clip I encourage
you to go watch this whole thing that we
about covered it all that children
should be able to do
whatever makes them happy and again this
is through line the anecdotal versus
empirical and gaslighting you this is
narcissism all the kids we've seen
tonight shouldn't need to be activists
they should get to dress how they want
go to the right bathroom for them and
play the sports they want to play we are
working toward the goal of every trans
kid knowing that they are loved valued
and indispensable as Dolly Parton loving
weird pets owning freaking dope
individuals and never ever going back to
a point where anyone feels that if they
appear on TV they have to hide behind a
[ __ ] plant so this is what they do
they conflate love with full-fledged
support for any decision that a child
makes if my kid can't can't eat
exclusively Pop-Tarts does that mean I
don't love them
it makes them happy
if your kid needs to be parented he
needs to learn to be part of a society
you need to know how it works he doesn't
need a friend who lets him do whatever
they want exactly it's unbelievable to
think that that's a good idea and to
think and again that combined with the
empirical evidence that we have as it
relates to these medical decisions we
what we know is bad
no everything but almost all of what we
know is bad
it's we love all of them look
doesn't mean that you don't love you
don't love your son or your daughter if
they suffer from some kind of serious
condition that maybe they need to be
institutionalized for does it mean you
don't love your son if your son becomes
addicted it develops a chemical
dependency and you send them to rehab
he's gonna be mad at you
he feels good doing it in that moment
and you're gonna say are you comparing
uh trans of people to drug addicts no
I'm not comparing them to drug addicts
but certainly we are talking about
exogenous hormones we are talking about
medical intervention often drugs
that will cause long-term ill health
effects
that would require
a responsible parental figure to
intervene in the correct way none of
that has to do with not loving your
children don't be gaslit into believing
you're crazy or that you're not
compassionate and why by the way is the
personal happiness mean that fleeting
feeling of what feels good why is that
the virtue to Trump all other virtues at
this at this point in time I don't know
when that happened we weren't raised
with that as kids I'd always say don't
do that not to put it but I like doing
it yeah but it's wrong
oh okay but it feels good it's wrong
oh now I know but it feels good to drink
uh to create a graveyard at Burger King
of every single soda imaginable and go
back for 19 refills he goes well you're
probably not going to feel good in an
hour or two and don't do it because it's
bad for you now extend that hour or two
the delayed reaction of five ten years
and that exact same scenario that parent
doesn't love you because they're not
letting you do whatever it is that you
want
again something else really important we
see throughout this entire segment in
order to make you believe that you are
not compassionate in order to make you
believe that you're a bad person for
holding your opinions which is what they
always do you're racist you're sexist
you're homophobic
you hate women and in this case you hate
women because you believe they shouldn't
be at a biological disadvantage at their
own sports it's the gasoline that takes
place and then we bring it back to and
you know uh
what we really should do is what feels
good that is classic narcissism it is a
way to manipulate you to silence anyone
who doesn't agree with them
why to lay it all at the altar of
self-worship the sacrifice to what makes
me feel good in the moment
this is this this is there's a reason
legislation has had to exist across the
country this is for the soul of our
country the idea that men and women are
fundamentally interchangeable and the
idea that parental rights are a thing
that's as important as it gets
thank you uh I think I'm going to make
use of this uh hit the like button hit
share we're going to go to mug Club
YouTube I hope you enjoyed it I know you
didn't piss off
foreign
[Music]